[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Таврія
Олешки]
Завжди хочеться людині бути вільною,
робити те, що подобається.
Не просто ходити з сьомої чи дев'ятої ранку
до шостої вечора на роботу,
не те, щоб коли захотів,
[Альберт Федотов
Виноградав]
а щоб йшов на роботу —
як на свято.
Виноградом я почав займатися
вісім-дев'ять років тому.
Але так, щоб професійно, — два роки.
Колекцію таку трошки збирав.
А зараз я вже весь у винограді.
Я знаю такий вислів,
що треба займатись тим, де важко.
Я люблю виноград.
Я все життя
хотів займатись виноградом.
Це перше, це — головне.
У мене колекція —
більше ста сортів.
Це не дуже велика колекція,
я знаю виноградарів,
у яких набагато більше.
І кожного року нові й нові форми,
і воно все красивіше, ягоди все більші,
ґрона — масивніші.
Ми називаємо так один одного,
і нас, виноградарів, так називають —
хворими людьми.
Так, воно так і є,
але ця хвороба — то виноград.
Якщо захворів, то все, всі гроші — на нові сорти.
Такі гроші, якби ви знали,
скільки коштують нові сорти...
Жінка моя не знає.
Я зараз роблю третю обломку
зелених пагонів.
І це надихає, весна, там ще нічого немає,
а тут вже, бачите, які грона.
А коли врожай!
То є добре, то душа співає.
Тут також я вирощую саджанці.
Але перше — це ягода,
і я роблю трошки вина.
Для цього в мене особлива
окрема колекція винних сортів.
Не «Ізабелла», не «Лідія»,
як у всіх кажуть.
Кожного дня на ринку питають ці сорти.
Я кажу: я цим не займаюся.
В мене більше всього це європейські:
французькі, німецькі сорти,
грузинські, вірменські.
Переважно вони
ще не дають врожаю,
тому що тільки закладена
плантація невеличка.
Але я вже п'ю своє вино,
наприклад, «Шардоне».
У мене цього року
дуже добре «Шардоне».
Щоб почали гроші відбиватись у винограді —
потрібно три, чотири роки.
Ваші гроші «заморожені».
Тому взяти, наприклад, два гектари
та поставити теплиці
і засадити виноградниками — це дуже важко.
Я продав машину і поставив теплиці.
Був занепад виноградного промислу, коли вирубували:
була боротьба з пияцтвом,
алкоголізмом, тоді — «Вирубати всі виноградники!»
Дуже багато було вирубано.
Занепад галузі був повністю.
Може і казали так, що не до цього,
не до винограду,
не до родзинок, не до вина.
Це були дев'яності,
початок двохтисячних років.
А зараз все більше
і більше винограду вже.
Особливо на Херсонщині.
По всій Україні виноград вирощують.
Я не думав, що під Києвом вирощують виноград.
Так, аж бігом, вирощують!
Хворі люди і там є.
І вони вирощують, то є добре.
Це ж як вірус, ми хворі люди,
це — вірус.
Воно видно одразу,
коли стоїш з ягодами —
виноградар іде
і в нього очі горять.
Дуже тісно спілкуємося.
Наприклад, в мене друзі є
і в Італії, і в Індії.
І по всій Європі, і в Іспанії, так що...
Не кажу вже про Україну.
Вчимося один у одного.
От скільки років я вже займаюся,
і я щодня усвідомлюю,
що я ще багато чого не розумію.
І коли ти над цією рослиною працюєш,
то не можна кричати.
Не можна лаятись,
не можна щось робити поспіхом.
Не можна щось забути.
Бо один день, приморозок,
ти проспав, не встиг — і все.
Року твоєї роботи немає.
Тому немає дрібниць.
Немає часу сказати: «Я завтра зроблю».
Якщо потрібно зробити сьогодні —
треба робити сьогодні.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олександр Слобода]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Polly K]
[Субтитрувальниця
Іра Жукевич]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]